проросійські кандидати прямі кути
євро, що послала на сході з таким і
заголовком і вийшла багата ну візьми впав
і справах пісня про ізраїльський вибір у
молдові це болгарії в бік краї нах
прямо кути кандидатів соціалісти з
проросійською ми зрозуміли та ми пішли
молдавські може і гордон і відкрито ви
знаєте крим російським і за клікають
узвар танець прибрати та з'їсть інші
болгарин румен дбайливо виступаючи за знає
тебе з росія санте
і зближення знаю про те експерт батьки
паніку вати з дроту та їх промо
заяву бокс тусуюся на передвиборчий
популізм
і захарова не через фактор там момент
повстання 10 лиття більше 50-ти
сотки у торгівлі на мобілу молдови
виклала на с і менше 20 на росію
тарик молдова великий експорт овалу
втрачена нижче в росію я хочу додон оповідь
про та догляду про асоціацію з c виробляючи
до
економічні катастрофи в край немає провини
та й так логічно проросійським чіп про
європейським він просто знаєш про всю нішу
вибрати його та дістати я добра ви cross
the way cake or плойки біг на адже забув
і до обожнення вони нові молдавські вони
болгарські президенти не зможе сама
стіни повернутий і вектор своїх краєн вигляд
є до Росії
отже пасата президента в державах
травня символічну роль ми з петром до
парламентської by 6 мани не можете хвали
ось і важливих рішень атакою by 6 pack
ще у жадібного на мої
про queen того молдован і що нам є про
болгарії у євросоюзі видно і на тарілку
Але роль пивних на злитки для України
віктор умовці кандидатів в орто чіка ти
a supple його збоку молдови жити
експерти а че там у придністров'я
з ще утворюється російські війська
хочу новий президент молдови з правді
виконуючи свої вбити anki сюди парі
орієнтації свої країни падали вигляд заходу
назад в орбіту Росії з мужності райт і
нові проблеми для psp до україни все ж
болгарії то там у лайки нового
президента матами менеджер пливун
україну щось санкції проти Росії
сторони будуть продовження чогось у рудні
новий президент ще не вступатиме на
посаду задум з прямота нового
президента Болгарії як абсолютно
проросійського політика всі заручини
отже таємниці вимагаю висновків з china to all
і шила б'ю я зняття санкцій із Москви
атева магазинчик район є теж завдання
для ключових людей євросоюзу купу то
сигнал на сході Європи і незабаром хват і
палетку середині союзу піцу новий
експерт